thank you good morning
my name is ulandari I'm the CEO of pity
Nirvana Sagara is the processor and
exporter of pasteurized crab meat with a
species blue swimming crab
good morning my name is Hema I have
founder and managing director of my
company Bali sustainable so we are
distributor a simple product for Hotel
restaurant and director customer too
good morning all my name is
I'm working for the minister of marine
Affairs and Fisheries in Indonesia so
good morning my name is
you can call me Amar I'm representative
Indonesian Fisheries undergraduate
Association
my position is Deputy Secretary General
3 Our member consists of academics
practitionary uh politician and fishery
actors my organization focused for
providing assistance
mentoring Improvement and advocacy for
good morning my name is utari I am
co-founder and chief sustainability
officer of Aruna Aruna is an integrated
Fisheries Commerce we connecting small
scale Fishers and connect them to Global
Market with the technology
okay good good morning ladies and
gentlemen my name is
chief of research community service and
quality assurance in my University my
university is Raja Ali Hadi Maritime
University so we are the first Maritime
University in Indonesia and now we're
still the only one University
so sustainability especially what you
have in New Hampshire like this official
game will be part of my interest so if I
learned today maybe I can adapt
something in my country in the future
good morning representative Jeff Coley
representing Manchester
um
Vice chair of the fish and game
committee
and I am chairman James Blaine chairman
of the fish and game committee uh I'm on
my fifth term here in the state house
which is our terms are two years so
um as a in my my private life I'm a
senior technical writer for an
industrial tools company and then uh
fish and game is my focus here in the
okay good morning
I am Carol Brown uh this is my first
term here in the legislature I'm
learning my way
I'm a biologist by education when I
worked for the State of New Hampshire
for the Department of Environmental
Services
and my main job there the last 16 years
was working in oil spill preparedness on
the coast of New Hampshire and working
closely with Chief Patterson from fish
and game on preparations for oil
wildlife and how do we protect oyster
farms and how do we protect our Lobster
Fisheries if there is a spill
thank you again
good morning representative Paul Tudor
Rockingham one serving the towns of
Northwood and Nottingham this is my
second term as a New Hampshire State Rep
my first term on Fish and Game
I'm a retired mechanical engineer from
General Electric as a matter of fact I
spent probably about four months in
Bandung Indonesia in the 90s setting up
uh jet engine Test Facilities there for
the CN 235 program I've had a great time
there I was in and out of the country
three or four times probably a month
good morning my name is Mike Willette I
am a representative first term from
Colebrook up in the north country of New
Hampshire
in my professional life I am a heavy
equipment sales representative and a
good morning representative Ben Ming
first term State Rep representing the
town of Hollis which is right on the
Massachusetts border
I step back from my professional life of
being a lawyer to be at home with my
four kids and learning a lot in this
good morning and welcome I'm Cherie
Patterson the chief of marine fisheries
for the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department
I'm not going to say how many years I
have been here it's been way too long
but thoroughly enjoyable and I look
so how would we like to start do we have
any questions for the committee first
would you like to hear about
interesting initiatives or maybe we
could even have the fish and game marine
department go over a a recap and an
overview of how our state runs our
aquaculture and and wild caught Marine
stuff
you want to hear
we want to hear first okay
good all right well we'll start with you
Sheree
thank you Mr chair
is that better
thank you
um an overview of how New Hampshire
[Music]
um
maintain sustainable Fisheries is that
is that why you guys want to hear
essentially
it um
the the department is
generally
for let's put this way Coastal Fisheries
are are in large part migratory
based on that
the rules and regulations that are
created to maintain sustainable
Fisheries are two-part actually
three-part the first part is the
Magnuson Stevens Fisheries conservation
act it was voted in back in the 70s and
has been through many amendments since
then
and what it does is it allows
guidance and some regulations as to how
to effectively
maintain
sustainable Fisheries
what this act does is also it creates a
series of coastal councils that work
with the industry works with the states
to come up with rules and regulations on
based on fishery management plans and
based on science as to how to maintain
sustainable Fisheries
it also has
an integral part of national standards
that will be inclusive of the industry
and still maintaining conservation needs
based again based on science
so we have a New England fisheries
management Council
Mid-Atlantic fisheries management
Council and a South Atlantic fisheries
management Council that covers federal
waters which are Waters Beyond three
miles out to 200. statewaters is zero to
three miles
and it's the council's uh and and I'm
just saying those three councils cover
the Atlantic coast
uh we also have a governing body with
the Atlantic states marine fisheries
commission that deals with Fisheries
within those state water boundaries zero
to three miles
so what guides New Hampshire is these
two organizations governing
organizations the New England fisheries
management Council and the Atlantic
states marine fisheries commission that
have
divide it up so so to speak depending on
the life cycles of these Fisheries fish
and Fisheries
create fisheries management plans
and each year or each three or five
years these fishery management plans are
updated with science through stock
assessments and such
when there comes time where
decisions need to be made to adjust
these fisheries management plans is when
these organizations asmfc and New
England fisheries management Council get
together
and vote as a body so Atlantic states
marine fisheries commission is comprised
of of the voting body from Maine down
through Florida
the New England fisheries management
Council
governs
from Connecticut up through Maine
and again their their boundaries are
three miles to 200 or zero to three
miles
once we
make decisions based on
stock assessments and updating these
fishery management plans is when we come
back to our state waters or our state
body
and
present
rules or regulations to be voted through
to continue to maintain these
sustainable Fisheries
so sometimes on an annual basis I will
come before this body
to talk about
how to move forward with some rules and
regulations
as well as we listened to this body
um if they have thoughts on how they
would like to see additional
conservation measures or additional
measures to maintain sustainable
Fisheries within our statewaters
so that's kind of a quick recap
is there any questions I would like to
ask if you could go into explaining the
species that we have here as our our
common species because I'm sure that it
differs from what they're doing in
Indonesia and they might be interested
to know what where our Fisheries are
actually bringing in
um and and what our major species are
and our subspecies and even some of the
things we're doing with aquaculture such
you better just go
um
so our in New Hampshire our primary uh
economically viable fishery is the
American lobster Fishery
that is
[Music]
um
that is what what is coming in with our
largest Landings in our largest
economic viability to our coastline
we also again these Fisheries are
prosecuted not just within state waters
but also within federal waters that they
are allowed to come in and land from
federal waters
we also have ground fish Fisheries
our ground fish complex
consists of cod Pollock cake those sort
of um
species that are mid-water dwelling
species we also have flounders we have
your typical
saltwater species that are found along
the Atlantic coast and that migrate
as a chairman splain indicated we also
have our species within state waters
that really don't move around much like
oysters and clams and such
so for
um
are are more sedentary species that
aren't migratory
we have found that it's difficult to be
able to
sustain viable Fisheries because there's
such a huge population
of people that
um certainly are drawn to harvest these
species
and so a lot of times with
um in these conditions we just allow
residents to be able to harvest under
certain conditions and such so that we
however due to climate change and due to
just interests in general of harvesting
there has been encouragement for
agriculture to occur
so in New Hampshire currently our
primary agriculture species
are oysters
we also have muscles
muscle lines we have kelp lines
we have a small research also
agriculture communities that are
researching how to
raise trout or sea run trout or salmon
or these sort of species also but our
major Focus for agriculture in
statewaters is the oyster
species
great
um does anyone here want to add on to
anything as far as concerns and or
Sportsman situations maybe even touch on
the bill that we did have this year on
okay
I just have one quick statement and
Fish and Game
there are
a very Diversified organization they'll
have a section of Fish and Game who was
really focused on law enforcement but
they also have a section that is
biologists that are really taking care
of the species and the animals in the
area so they they have uh wear varied
hats
right and is there interest in the
freshwater stuff that we do as well or
are we focusing mainly on marine species
fresh water as well so
I could toss this back to Cherie again
to talk about our fresh water program
and we do we do raise uh fish that we
then release in and that keeps the
Sportsman able to go we don't have any
fresh water industry that I know of uh
but we have the Sportsman is that
correct
uh yeah for the most part that's correct
we have small bait Fisheries that are
that can be on a commercial basis but
for the most part our Inland Fisheries
uh
revolve around
cold water species and warm water
species so you have your cold water
species which are primarily your trout
we have brook trout brown trout rainbow
trout
and a warm water species such as your
bass your various bass your perch and
such so again we're a small state and
yet have a population that's very
interested in recreating for these
species
so we have
I'm not sure if I've got this number
correct
um I know we used to have seven
hatcheries I'm not sure we still have
some I thought there were five right now
um that raise uh the various uh trout
that I just mentioned as well as a
landlocked Atlantic salmon
so these are
um for the trout is primarily a put and
take fishery we raise them up to be a
harvestable size or an exciting size for
recreational Harvesters to angle for
and
um
we do we do release uh fingerlings you
know your small species in some of our
our higher elevation ponds and such to
give that excitement also for
recreational Anglers to be able to
harvest if they decide to hike in
distances to do that sort of fishing
we do not have any hatcheries for our
warm water species we just make sure
that we have rules or regulations in
place that will reduce the amount of
harvest per person to make sure that
these species are maintained sustainably
thank you
can you just go over briefly because I
think it's important an important issue
as well when we talk about conservation
and how we conserve our Fisheries uh
striped bass I know there was just an
area that was closed recently due to uh
a die off of
fish being killed after being released I
just want to talk about how we manage
that species
so our striped bass species are
migratory species and they are managed
through the Atlantic states marine
fisheries Commission
they right now are in a period of
um oh being overfished over
and overfishing was occurring
so the minute those categories popped up
in front of us at the asmfc level
that put us into creating a 10-year
we're not recovering very well so what
has happened is probably due to climate
change we don't have good recruitment
occurring
and warmer waters are definitely
affecting
um
how the fish react to being under stress
so if they're being harvested alive
they're being angled
fished on a lot Catch and Release sort
of scenario in warm Waters
then they will start dying
so the state of Maine just recently
closed the Saco River
due to this sort of event we had a
striped bass that were or Maine had
striped bass that were in their rivers
that were being heavily fished a lot of
Catch and Release the waters were
warming up and then they were noticing
at a at a higher quantity than what we
want to see
during a period of time that we're
trying to recover this this particular
I I don't know uh how it works for you
folks so
that there's always a question here
about sustainability as driven by our
federal government versus the rights of
fishermen and earning their livelihoods
so I don't know I I don't know if Sharia
wanted to touch base on that certainly
controlling how fishermen operate leads
into the sustainability of this history
but it also always has some impact on
those people's uh livelihood so
I I'd be interested to know how it works
yeah thank you for the question so we
have the same facing we are facing the
same problem you know in Indonesia as
well so uh the uh business and the
scientist needs is uh
something like the opposite direction
you know the person may want more face
but the same the scientists oh no you
cannot catch more fish but you have to
preset the resource so sometimes we have
yeah option between there then we take
the uh
what we call it's not like there will be
a solution but uh we have to choose the
best option for that to preserve the
resource even uh it's her the pressure
man maybe you know I know maybe in here
it's it happened as well and then when
we take uh we create the policy or
regulation to manage our business but
maybe it will not be it will not good
for the businessman sometimes
yeah
yeah thank you
I'll go again if you want absolutely uh
on the handout here it talks about uh it
says to broaden understanding with a
wider range of advocacy tools and
mechanisms Etc
so Chief Patterson can speak to this
much better than I can but
there are a number of efforts in the
state of New Hampshire and Maine where
volunteer groups come together
and and Advocate they'll come here to
testify to this committee to advocate
for a position and I think it's a really
important part of of how this works in
New Hampshire as the the chairman
mentioned a short time ago
this past year this past three years
five years
there was a a bill proposed to allow
scuba divers
to harvest Lobsters by hand from the
bottom
and it was very controversial there was
a lot of discussion about the the
sustainability of the lobster fishery
and would it impact that and it it came
down to quite a conversation in here so
but Chief Patterson might be able to
better talk about sort of those advocacy
kind of programs and the volunteer
efforts that happen but it's a it's a
really big part of I think how how New
Hampshire operates a fish and game
I'll put a plug in for there
unfortunately generally underfunded I
don't know if the same thing happens on
and I guess I'll follow up on that with
um more information about this bill that
we had that we dealt with uh
mostly we still have some cleanup to do
on it but it should be going into effect
after the Senate took a stab at doing
some changes to it one of the things
that came out of this whole discussion
on allowing divers to go down for
lobsters was that the divers were seeing
a lot of what we call ghost traps these
are fishing traps that have become
separated from their line and are now at
the whims of the ocean
getting tangled up in balls but they
still continue to catch animals that
crawl into them that then die and become
bait to attract more animals and so it's
difficult to work again work for your
sustainability if you've got
fishing traps that are fishing without
anybody being in charge of them
underwater
so we needed to come up with a way to
identify their locations and clean them
up and we're a little late coming to the
game compared to a state like Maine
Maine just to our North has a lot more
Lobster fishermen and they have a much
bigger problem with the traps that have
become separated and so they started a
cleanup program
that was done by a volunteer
organization working in conjunction with
the lobstermen just in the Boothbay
Harbor area alone where they were able
to pull out and remove thousands of
traps that had been
found washed up in areas where they were
underwater wrapped in balls and um
most of them were recycled but some of
them were still in condition where they
could be returned to their owners and
and refurbished and put back in the
water
um but that cleanup is one of the things
that we now have an active Bill uh with
potentially some money allocated to help
with the cleanup of that and push
ourselves towards trying to remove these
underwater uh ghost traps so that they
aren't continually catching species and
we have photos that it's not just the
lobsters that crawl into these lobster
traps we have pictures of some cod that
were inside and trapped and can't get
out and
um all kinds of things
so that's another aspect where we're
working on on uh trying to
trying to be working hand in hand with
the lobstermen we've got a little bit of
a harder time convincing them that it's
a problem they need to deal with then
Maine did Maine they were all right on
board jumped on onto it and
when he says this was controversial
there was a lot of
arguing between the lobstermen and the
divers and the environmental groups
about how big is this problem really
um of course at first the lobsterman
didn't want to say the problem even
existed
doesn't happen to us
um but we've got the issue currently
being solved in Massachusetts and Maine
how could we be different right
um and when we had pictures brought up
from the ocean bottom that showed them
we know there's a problem how extensive
that problem is we still don't know we
need a study to see how many traps are
down there where they're located and and
how big of a problem it is but we've got
a step forward now with this bill where
we're going to allocate some funding and
try to start to recognize the problem
and address it
um and then I guess I'll toss back to
Cherie now so she can add more context
all right thank you I love this hot
topics
um
so
as many countries and ours included
ghost gear has been a severe problem not
just with in this case lobster traps but
also Nets
we don't see too much of that in our
statewaters with Nets because we have a
pretty
um
tightly regulated
way of being able to fish or you can't
fish using Nets
a lot of times it's you have to be
actively fishing a net you have to be on
site
we don't allow most mobile gear in our
statewaters so yes our probably our
primary ghost gear issue is the lobster
gear
we've decided to come at it many years
ago from a mini-pronged approach which
unfortunately
has not been inclusive of in-water gear
so our many prong approach started out
with
doing Beach cleanup so the lobster
fishing industry for over 20 years has
been with the help of Fish and Game
organizing
Beach cleanup time frame so usually
after a winter we have
storms and such you see a lot of gear
that will come up onto the coast and
that is cleaned up before the
uh the summer residents start to show up
and then we entered into an MOA with
another state agency who is responsible
for state parks and such
so that they are also allowed to now
pick up uh gear that are on the beach or
in shallow water that they may find that
would be interrupting people recreating
at state parks and such
keeping in mind that for lobster gear we
have a regulation that indicates that
essentially only a member of law
enforcement
or
Fish and Game designee person
or a lobster Harvester themselves
can only pick up gear
it's considered private property here
and therefore it's pretty constrained as
to who can actually pick up
gear that appears to be ghost gear or
dare lickier
the next manner of approaching this was
being able to provide a way of disposing
of gear
for the various fishing industries
we were informed that many Town
municipality uh disposal or dumps were
not were no longer taking
fishing gear
and this then kind of promoted
a out of sight out of mind thought from
the fishing industry that if they just
go dump it out in the water you don't
you don't see it again
so what we did is we created these what
we call fishing for energy bins and
opportunities
such that any uh
person in the fishing industry
can
dump particular things into this fishing
for energy bin
and where it it goes is a company called
covanta in Massachusetts that will burn
a particular
gear types or it'll go to
snitch or Steel in other words your
lobster traps and such which are metal
for recycling
so it's a complete recycling program at
this point in time that the fishing
industry has been utilizing to its
fullest extent they do bring in gear
that they will no longer be using and it
and it doesn't end up in places that it
shouldn't end up in if it's no longer
viable gear
we also
um in in our travels of
picking up gear off the coast and such
if the if it is viable gear we will
contact the individuals there they all
have to have some sort of identification
on their gear
we notify them and we give them the
opportunity of two weeks to come and
pick it up if they don't pick it up then
it goes into the recycling bin and it's
and so now with this year's help with
the legislative process and this
committee
we
should be able to
obtain some funds to be able to now work
with gear that is in the water as you
can imagine it's very hard to locate
gear that's in water if it's in shallow
water that's a little bit easier but you
know we have
it would be harder to be able to detect
where gear derelict gear is and such
without technology such as side scan
sonar
um
as just an example to be able to find
where this gear is
we have encouraged
communities that such as the diving
community and such to give us a call if
they find a ball of gear so that we can
find it
and recover it
as a fish and game agency or we have
actually
had Coast Guard help us a couple times
with some big balls and they had a big
bigger ship than ours to be able to
recover
these gears and again we will do similar
to what we do with all recovered gear if
it looks like it's a viable gear we'll
contact the owner if not then it goes to
the recycling bin and such
so that's where we are with this many
pronged approach to try and deal with
um
and prevent derelict gear in ghost gear
thanks
and touching on that
um I was wondering if you could also
explain the um the depths of water that
we have off of our Coastline because I
know it does drop off precipitously and
quickly past the Isle of Shoals but
we've got lots of shallow area between
here and there and where Indonesia is a
mostly island country they probably have
a lot of familiarity with the way that
we have a relationship with the Isle of
Shoals and things get fished in between
but then we've got the deep water as
well
and I'm not familiar enough with how our
depths vary
so New Hampshire's coastline is
um is complex habitat it has got a
variety of Rocky
um areas got rocky Shoreline we have
beaches we have Sandy areas we have
muddy areas when I had described earlier
about statewaters being between zero and
three miles that also encompasses if
you're going around Islands
so we have a series of islands off of
our Coast called the Isles of Shoals
and it's pretty much split in half
between New Hampshire and the state of
Maine
but you also when you talk about state
waters you're also talking about those
three miles around
we do have
um
varying depths you know of course from
the shoreline we have depths out by the
shoals that are at 60 feet then we also
can drop down to 200 feet in various
areas both between our Shoreline and the
shoals as well as beyond the shoals so
it it becomes a little bit
tenuous as to how you can identify where
where gear might be and how
varied the the recovery of gear will
have to be considered when we are able
great anybody else uh Carol
I see that on Wednesday thank you Mr
chair I see that on Wednesday you're
going to the Nashua National Fish
Hatchery
you can re you can help me because my my
knowledge is old
have they abandoned
the salmon program
so for years I how many years and how
much money was spent in the attempt to
bring migratory salmon back into the
rivers of New Hampshire and I think the
federal government was the main driver
of that but they used to do that from
that Hatchery but I didn't know if you
could address if that's as a failed
program
so um
very good question
[Music]
um
so the
the
um and state agencies that try and work
in concert to
restore Fisheries or provide other
sustainable ways of harvesting Fisheries
for example our hatcheries with trout
so decades ago
clear understanding that the Atlantic
salmon
so you have landlock Atlantic salmon
literally those are landlocked in our
lakes and such and you have the
migratory Atlantic salmon
in our major Coastal Rivers between
Connecticut and Maine it was determined
that these anatomous species that um
live most of their lives in salt water
but come into fresh water to spawn and
they spend
for Atlantic salmon they'll spend two
years in fresh water before they migrate
back out to the ocean
so
we weren't seeing the returns coming
back to our freshwater reaches of their
habitat
of course these freshwater reaches have
been
severely truncated by dams
and most of these dams up until the 60s
and 70s had no fish passage on them and
even now there's very little fish
passage on most of the dams that are
within the Atlantic Salmons
reach or within their
their cycle their migratory cycle
so Connecticut
was the first to really detect an issue
with a declining Atlantic salmon
population in their river systems of
course
um as you can imagine climate change has
been occurring for decades it is
something that just occurs recently it's
occurring over decades and you have some
key species
that might be the canary in the mind
they might be the detectors that there
are changes that are occurring and in
Connecticut it was determined that there
was
um
that was the southernmost reach at the
time of the Atlantic salmon the Atlantic
salmon again go from on the Atlantic
coast
um
go from Connecticut or dead right up
so there was a federal push
to try and restore the Atlantic salmon
back into some of these rivers and it
started out in Massachusetts in
Connecticut
um
where they started putting in fish
passage systems and dams
and had hatcheries both in Vermont and
in we had a small one in New Hampshire
have a small one in New Hampshire the
Nashua uh National Fish Hatchery
where we were or the feds were
raising
the juveniles and stocking them out into
the ocean
so that they were kind of skipping that
that in fresh water reach of their life
cycle
in order to try and be more viable
considering the freshwater
habitat was not very hospitable to them
and then all of a sudden you just kind
of started to see this creep going north
of the Atlantic salmon in Northern
rivers from the Connecticut River also
start experiencing this concern of
diminished populations of Atlantic
salmon
so in the
90s
um
it was determined that the
Inland or the freshwater habitats were
going to continue not to be hospitable
for the Atlantic salmon population in
those particular River reaches
and the
federal government
that had these hatcheries the U.S fish
and wildlife service
decided to change species raising
different species that would be more of
a viable fishery to be able to restore
so right now the Nashua Hatchery is
Raising American Chad
or the Connecticut and the Merrimack
rivers and when they have some extra
they get we get some of those extra
juveniles also to stock in our
freshwater reaches and American Shadow
or anadramus species also they'll go out
to the ocean and come around when they
come back when they decide they are
thank you
anything else from my committee members
uh chairman spielen if you don't mind
yep our visitors have a lot of questions
they would like to ask if you could give
them time absolutely we're uh where I
was going to go right over to them
actually if there was no other comments
from the from the side here
but I'll let Ben Ming do one question
and then we'll pop right over there
just very briefly to um your earlier
question of ocean depth maybe it might
be useful to talk about
um water temperatures because we have I
don't know two or three months of
hot weather but our ocean water tends to
be fairly cold
anybody who tries to swim around here
knows that
however it is getting warmer uh the Gulf
of Maine is actually one of the fastest
warming Waters
in the world today
uh there is a
a pinching so to speak of Colder Arctic
Waters
and our warmer gulp Waters that is
occurring and as a result of that we're
not getting the colder Waters coming
into the Gulf of Maine from the Arctic
that we uh used to so as a result we are
experiencing
um
a lot warmer
water
which has effects of
all of the trophic levels of species so
you know right down to your benthic
species your copepods which feed our
whales for example
or some species of our whales and shrimp
Northern shrimp we no longer have a
fishery for Northern shrimp because
again the the waters are too warm and
inhospitable to maintain
viable fishing opportunities for those
populations again these are some of
these species are canaries in the mine
and we're just going to be adapting to
these sort of conditions over the next
several decades or at least until the
okay let's turn it over to your first
questions I'll let you guys choose who
uh thank you chair so we have a lot of
questions but I try to simplify the
question
so we want to know uh how do you
establish the policy the policy maybe a
step behind you creating the policy you
know managing the freezer is limited
resources and you have to distribute
fairly and equally among the Fisheries
you know so we want to now
uh how do you set the policy for the
some issues and then uh what is the role
of the representative in here to you
know to affect the policy
and then whether is it a political issue
for the to affect the uh decision or the
policy thank you
so as Sheree had mentioned there's um
two governing bodies that that uh help
set the policy for the entire Atlantic
Sea Coast and then for our northern
states
um
the federal government has a lot of uh
say over everything that has to happen
along our whole Atlantic Coast at the
um
at the uh federal waters which was the
three miles and out and then for us the
zero to three miles in is uh more of
what we get to control as a state but we
also still have to fall on to the
guidance of that Atlantic states uh
fishing Council
um when an issue comes up that is
something that we need to address in our
state such as this derelict fishing gear
because it was being addressed in Maine
and in Massachusetts but we hadn't
really done anything regarding the gear
in water I want to make that clear we
had a successful program once it washes
up on shore but for everything that
remains hidden underwater
we didn't have a program but it became
an issue that we had to deal with with
our state itself
so that's when it comes to and our body
to make a legislative decision on trying
to find the best way to put forward a
regulation
that must be adhered to for our bodies
of water along the ocean
um anything that happens in the fresh
water is entirely done uh here by our
state and uh fish and game biologists
who advise us on the species population
and they make judgments uh with their
rules we have a process where not
everything has to come through the
legislature because that's a slow
process so we've given the fission game
department
um the ability to make rules that set
seasonal limits and catching methods and
come down to the point where they can
actually close off bodies of water or
change the methods of fishing within
certain areas to best manage the Inland
side of things
anything to add to that Cherie
no that was a pretty good cursory view
uh yes thank you for the explanation so
uh when there is uh you know the
fisherman need that convey to your
representative in here
uh can you interfere the policy or
decision to change the
policy or regulation
we that's where the the activist groups
and uh such come into play
um if if the fishermen as an industry
have an issue that they
really feel needs to be addressed they
will together
um contact us and ask for legislation to
be put in
um that will typically start with a
draft piece of legislation from a
handful of state representatives keep in
mind we have
quite a lot at 400 state representatives
we are actually the third largest
democratically elected body in the world
um so a handful of State reps would
draft some legislation and then it would
come to this committee
and
the fishermen would show up to testify
why do they wanted this bill what is the
purpose how's it going to affect them
sometimes it is because of something
they see that's coming out of the
federal regulations that might
caused them to lose their livelihood and
they want us to react to it as a state
and sometimes our hands are tied but
sometimes there's things we can do to
allow a balance between the needs of the
fishermen and the demands for
conservation from Washington or just in
general a rule from the Atlantic states
fisheries and that sort of thing
okay
I want to know as a scientist uh I'm
interested in how you do the stock
assessment so this is the the the the
the basic of information that you need
to decide something for the regulation
so who that uh legitimate to do the
research is it the University or some
research agency and after that when they
process the data those information pass
so you can make regulation about it yeah
thank you that's a great question
actually
um
we have biologists in fish and game in
our department that work for them
full-time uh part of their job is to
survey the wildlife in the state that is
uh crucial towards towards uh Sportsmen
and or our Industries and then there's
also the Atlantic Fisheries Council that
I assume does some sort of uh some
surveying as well and we've got the
federal government always involved in
trying to do some stuff as well so it's
I think there's multiple groups that
come at this measurement and I'm going
to now turn it over to Cherie to explain
more closely how we get all of our data
you did you did
you did a chair
um
combination of oh I should say a
collaboration actually effort
um yes within States
each state there are various agencies
that are responsible for natural
resources
or habitats right so
we are constantly out surveying or
sampling populations and such
our sister agency the Department of
Environmental services will be out doing
what a quality uh work so we can
collaborate
with them
for data you know this is just part and
parcel of all the data that's collected
other states are doing the same
as well as as uh chairman splain
indicated the federal government is also
the the two organizations I mentioned
the Atlantic state supreme Fisheries
commission and the New England fisheries
management Council they also have staff
that are responsible for data collection
and analyzes
so we all have large responsibilities of
monitoring what our populations are
doing including the migratory species
and that's the reason why you have these
organizations and
um
state agencies to be able to
recommend or to base decisions on
science and not something necessarily
that is based on subjectivity from an
industry or and such
what's really interesting and
fascinating actually is when we do go
through these processes the industry
does have input as we're going through
policy or or creating rules and
regulations
so that we do hear that we do listen to
that but
um if science doesn't necessarily back
up what the industry is observing on
their own then there are decisions that
have to be made through a policy
procedure to assure that
or try to ensure we're not putting
people out of business then we can reach
some sort of compromise where it's not
going to affect the sustainability
of their livelihoods as well as the
and do we get any of the data on fish
populations and species populations that
we're interested in out of the sportsmen
and fishermen themselves or is this
entirely driven by
our researchers and the researchers of
these organizations
oh it is yes it comes from everywhere
actually
um
part of the surveys are
can be done federally in collaborations
with States so we have a
a coastal survey that occurs
in Inland Fisheries
they primarily
determine population
um
and changes in population through their
their particular work of netting
um you know actually those sort of
methods of
long-term data sets and and the same
methodology to create those long-term
data sets where stable data sets can
create
better data than
sporadic data sets
UNH are our University Systems are also
in part
um
collecting data and providing not
necessarily towards stock assessments
and such but can provide
questions for us to be able to maybe
address if they're picking up something
that that state or federal agencies
aren't picking up but there are many
surveys that are being conducted
there's there's all sorts of
methodologies of as you as you probably
are
utilizing in your countries too to
assure that the data sets and the data
that you're working with are going to be
reliable and defensible because the
industry relies on that and it's very
important that they have their input and
that they have the confidence and the
data that you are
making decisions policy decisions on
and do we have any current
collaborations with unh
uh for any of this all the time
all the time yeah right now we're
collaborating with a rainbow smelt
project where UNH goes out and does work
for us in the spring
sorry just one quick statement
would you say it's a fair statement to
say that sometimes government can be
cumbersome but a fish and game and Des
have the authority and latitude if they
see some very
uh bad Trends happening they can't react
yes we can we certainly try and do that
absolutely
yeah I'm curious about these uh stock
assessment you conduct in here what is
the boundary for the free stock
assessment here are you divided between
the state water and federal water or
it's just uh one stock for the first
for the stock
um it varies uh depending on the courses
the species but yes some of their uh
Coastal species or Atlantic Ocean
species are divided up into stocks
absolutely based on their area based on
um DNA you know their genetics and such
we can make those determinations that
when we do create policy
and fisheries management that we are
relying on
maintaining stocks and not depleting one
and and
not depleting another right we want to
make sure that you keep stock separate
when you make policy and management
decisions
so could you give me an example for the
stock that you conduct with the federal
or with the uh commission something like
that
species
George's Bank
and then we have a gulf of Maine stock
so when we make
um fisheries management decisions
and when we do the sampling and such we
make sure that we are sampling both
stocks appropriately and efficiently so
that
um we're managing both stocks
based on the data that's coming out of
uh
yeah uh
support
thank you
so that depends everything
to do with species right
um
some species we've been successful very
successful with with implementing
regulations that then allow us to still
meet Market requirements for the
fishermen themselves and in some areas
we've made the fishermen unhappy and
I'll let Cherie talk about specific
examples but I think the Cod was one of
them
where we had to decrease on George's
bank for a while didn't we
and there's
we're also seeing a
lessening in the number of species of
what they were using as bait fish for
our lobster traps so they've switched
bait species in my understanding as well
um the previously abundant I don't
remember what it was that there was an
attic
um
not so abundant now so uh sometimes
we're successful sometimes it's not and
and I'm sure we've got some great
examples of extremely good successes and
then we've got some examples of where we
that's a really good question and it's
hard to
um
it's hard to Define right it's hard to
answer in all aspects
so under the Magnuson Stevenson Act
there is a requirement that you create
fishery management plans and further
amendments and addendums if need be
in order to address
restoration potential so if you have a
species or fishery that's um
overfishing or overfished
then you have a particular time limit
that you need to
um
restore them to
to a particular
time frame that was a viable Fishery
well with climate change
are other
natural
resource issues
that doesn't necessarily happen
so then you try during that time frame
say 10-year time frame of restoration
you try and continually adjust rules and
regulations to
um to manage the The Fishery because
that's all you can do you can't manage
natural mortality right you can't manage
what's happening in their environment
to a large degree so the pretty much the
only thing you can effectively manage is
the Fisheries themselves
so unfortunately that's when you get
into these issues that chairman
explained was speaking of where the
industry is happy at times and not happy
at other times because we're constantly
having to adjust based on our annual or
every three year stock assessment
process that creates the data that
informs us
is if we are
still on track
with our 10-year restoration plan
10-year being example
restoration plan
it's complex
and again if if their natural
environment is changing such
that it's something that the Fisheries
it's not the Fisheries fault that a
population
you can still only
regulate the Fisheries
to make sure that it doesn't become even
more depleted and an example of that as
I mentioned earlier is the northern
shrimp I think we're in our 13th or 14th
year of a moratorium on The Fishery
there's shrimp out there but they're at
such low levels that would not be able
to sustain The Fishery and their
and I believe she had a part of her
question when she was asking how we
if we've actually
actually we actually restored them to
their particular levels that we are
trying to
um
get them to in their 10-year period so
we always have
um a period of time that we know
the populations and the Fisheries were
doing well so say there was a period of
time in
um
the 1990s that
was a good population to support a
particular amount of Fisheries
then we would try and restore it to that
level
and that's what those those fishery
management plans try and do and try to
adjust for
based on
how many people we have out there
fishing for them which could be
diminished or increased based on
what the populations were before and how
many individuals you had fishing on them
so you want to maintain a particular
number of fishers or Harvesters
based on a particular population
if you increase the Harvesters and still
have this small population then you're
in an overfished issue if you have the
the same amount of Harvesters but a
declining population
you still have the same problem of being
overfished or overfishing is occurring
so you always want to maintain some
level that you recognized as being
successful or fully restored at some
point based on the
amount of Fisheries that we're fishing
Indonesia
[Music]
foreign
communion
um
[Music]
foreign
very good question
um
we do decide the budget for fish and
game
not this committee
the entire house
and that budget actually goes in front
of a different committee the finance
committee
um
for their determination as to whether
it's okay and whether it needs more when
a certain special circumstance pops up
we may allocate funding in this
committee to address a certain issue
we do not as a legislature we do not
get involved in the market
and the fishermen
aside from providing the guidelines
under which they must work
so we're not directly financially tied
into the results of our fishing and
we're not
we don't have any impact on the revenue
that phishing provides to the state
aside from
our general guidelines that we provide
for them we don't do any kind of
subsidies to the fishermen
um
and and that sort of thing
if a Federal Regulation from Washington
came down and said that it was going to
affect say the type of gear that
everyone had to use
well then we would have to work to try
to make sure that there was as little
impact to our fishermen as possible
while they transitioned into that gear
we usually don't do that through the
Act of subsidy where we would give them
money to purchase the new gear but more
in making sure there's enough time
available for them to move into the new
gear from the old gear without impacting
their operations
I think that the best situation that we
have for all of that industry is that we
in New Hampshire don't have a sales tax
so we don't have to concern ourselves
with tax policy that might impact
negatively our fishermen
and that's probably why we're more of a
hands-off when it comes to the industry
and we focus on funding the department
that
enforces and governs the the regulations
we've put in place that makes the rules
that are more Nimble than the laws that
we put in place and I believe that we as
a partner to these other Fisheries
there's there's contributions we make
into that
um
so now I'll again toss it over to Cherie
thank you
um
you explained it very well
on a state level
there's very little opportunity to
provide funds to to an industry
um that might be
in trouble
however because there's so much
interaction with the federal government
and these other organizations Atlantic
states marine fisheries Commission
that
oftentimes there could be disaster funds
available congressionally there could be
um
other funds available federal funds that
is available
to help the industry adjust to rules and
regulations whether that be monetarily
or whether that be
literally the government supplying funds
for us to maybe buy the gear and and
provide it to the industry if there's
gear change requirements so it just
depends on what the requirements are
that might be
um
affecting them
and as to whether it's a disaster the
Atlantic hearing which is senator's plan
Senate a representative displaying I'm
sorry I just elevated him
um
indicated that we've had a collapse of
the Atlantic hearing population in the
Gulf of Maine
as a result
um
for bait species
the lobster industry has had to move to
menhaven species which is a very robust
population along the east coast now
and they harvest them for the use of
bait because the regulations now to
harvest Atlanta caring are very strict
and very constricting
so
the state
um
as well as the other states between
Rhode Island and Maine declared to the
federal government
that we wanted to see a Fisheries
disaster being declared so that goes in
front of Congress congress makes those
decisions as to whether they will fund
Fisheries disasters such as those
and then once all that clears the
federal process
then funds come to each state and the
state disperses Fish and Game disperses
those funds to those that were affected
yes sir
just a quick question
a lot I know a lot of fish and games
funding is self-funded through licenses
from Sportsman other things what
percentage of your overall budget
ballpark is uh self-funded and how much
um for fish and game it is primarily a
self-funded agency
we also
have the opportunity to get
for some of our a lot of our work
federal funds through
U.S fish and wildlife service or NOAA
fisheries and such
and that percentage
technically it's
75-25 but in reality it is not it's uh a
little bit less you know like 60 40
percent uh fish and game funds to to
federal funds
um
it's it Fish and Game struggles at times
because we are constrained we do have
some general funds that comes to the
Department
uh for example for search and rescue
because it's not just the stakeholders
the fish and game stakeholders your
Anglers your hunters and such that are
lost or need rescuing and such so there
is some general funds that come to fish
and game but it's uh
primarily a
self-sourcing agency
and we get a
bunch of money in the Pitman act from
purchase of uh angling gear and hunting
equipment uh ammunition and such correct
correct those are those are where some
of the federal funds come from
absolutely
[Music]
uh
sorry
foreign
okay another good question
um
the way that we govern
um the industry bringing fish into our
state for sale is through the landing of
the fish if they bringing the fish into
a port in New Hampshire they have to be
licensed to land the fish here and they
buy those licenses
we have as the United States something
in our Constitution called the Commerce
Clause which prohibits one state from
charging any kind of tariffs on another
state for the importing or exporting of
of things between states so there's
absolutely no
collaboration needed even if it's a
migratory species of fish for a
person who's licensed to land the fish
in New Hampshire to then sell them to
somebody who doesn't live here
and now again I'll throw it to Sheree in
so you've heard me speak about the
council and the commission where the
asmfc and the New England fisheries
management Council those are made up of
all the states so when a fishery policy
management decision is made
all of the states enacted so they they
should be the same up and down the coast
for where those where those fish species
exist an example would be
um
I don't know striped bass
where
everybody has the same regulation
or harvest
States can be more conservative than
what the policy that all the states
voted on
have
but
um
as for creating equal rules and
regulations that's what those
organizations do and as Representatives
Blaine indicated that a lot of times the
rules and regulations for Commerce come
into effect as to how they can be
um
discluded or included
any other questions
the question
or Mr chairman I want to know how
important the Fisheries industry for New
Hampshire and how is the presentation
itself Fisheries comparing to the other
industry and I'm sure it's going to
impact for the state to make the
priority for any Fisheries policies
thank you
so the Fisheries in New Hampshire are
not
our biggest industry in New Hampshire
but the lobster industry is our biggest
fishery in New Hampshire uh as far as
the dollar amount that it brings into
the state
[Music]
um
and
I would say that uh probably number one
we might be up there with paper and
Timber
um
anybody else got any idea what our other
top industries are I know we've got a
huge blossoming biomed industry now and
the high tech has always been uh doing
well and it's doing better and now that
there's more remote working
um
representative Ming do you have anything
to add to that
um I believe it's the medical industry
I think that that might be our topic
okay uh anybody else
rep roulette
I know in the northern half of the state
it's the tourist industry is really the
largest industry I almost forgot tourism
I mean uh but yeah no I mean uh
we we're blessed here with a
multi-seasonal tourist industry in other
words in the winter time we don't shut
down completely we shift our tourism to
ski areas and winter sports
uh winter activities like ice fishing
and things that people do in the
outdoors and then in the summertime it's
of course summer tourists hiking uh
tourism throughout all of our mountain
ranges plus also on the Seacoast
although as we mentioned the water stays
pretty darn cold so it swimming is not a
big thing even in even in our warmest
months it's still cold enough that you
um you'll get goosebumps when you go in
the water
um
yeah but I'd say lobster is do you know
how many what the dollar amount is
approximately
it's in the five million dollar range
for just Landings that doesn't include
the economics associated with the
infrastructure and such five million is
only for lobster or all the Fisheries
that would be just the lobster portion I
believe
so
um
it's probably down around our fourth or
fifth probably I would say the fisheries
and we have a very short coastline
of all the New England states we've got
the shortest
um and so it's uh what 16 miles or
something like that 18. yeah if you want
to stretch it it's 18. if we count the
all around the Isle of Shoals we can add
in a couple
um it's very short so
um that's why we don't have large scale
um Fisheries of other types we don't
have a lot of
um Fisheries that choose to have a uh
presence on our Seacoast that go out
into those international waters or into
the the Deep federal waters to do the
deep sea net fishing or any of that and
we've got very strict regulations on how
Nets can be used along our Coastline so
um that's why it ends up being the
lobster that brings in the most uh it's
the one that's constantly going
year-round the other ones tend to be
smaller in nature
but although we do have I think it's the
smallest Coastline in the United States
Rhode Island is a little bigger than we
are so yes we have the smallest
Coastline in the U.S here in New
Hampshire but I think it's important
it may not just be a a dollar figure a
lot of people come here
because of the coastline and a lot of
those people that are coming here are
recreational fishermen and of course
that that spins off to boat sales and
all of those other spin-offs that happen
because of the folks coming here to do
the fishing so you may not because it's
such a small Coastline you may not be
able to just compare the the money
exactly compared to the rest of the
state but it's a it's a really important
piece of what New Hampshire is as our
Coastline and the attraction that it has
for people to come here
um I I and I think
a lot of these are great questions for
Wednesday afternoon
when you're going to see the Yankee
Fisherman's Cooperative who would have
maybe slightly different uh ideas than
I want to share uh something that may be
quite different in our country so in
your
in the state maybe or in Eastern nation
individual fishermen should have a
permit yeah
so in Indonesia when you go to Indonesia
then you don't need a permit to do
fishing so you can fishing all you want
you can catch all your ads uh but uh I
think uh
we didn't count that that
assessment for that because um because
uh fishermen sometimes they get the fish
that the individual who fishing and
sometimes they didn't care if they did
get this wasting time for that and then
also some practice that some people who
do the aquaculture they do something
like a charity when they release some of
their larvae or the fried to the to the
nature even though they didn't assess
also the survival rate
thus those uh fish alive or not but they
do that for generous to the generosity
to the to the nature so yeah
maybe uh This Is this different part
because
we still didn't get direct effect to the
uh how to say the global warming and
season changing and so on but I'm sure
in the future those will happen also in
Us in the Tropic area so that make me uh
make me build a one of concern that uh
we Indonesia should start anticipating
and regulate somehow in order to sustain
because uh we cannot just uh rely on
just relax and so on and so on because
when those happen maybe or they need too
late to to our country so yeah very
great information for for you all to me
thank you
yeah that's very interesting um
I would say that
without a huge buy-in of cooperation
it is almost impossible to
um
manage species even if you have the data
unless you know how many people are
fishing and you have uh somehow
permitted them and I'm not going to
advocate for Indonesia to start charging
fishermen for licenses however uh a
voluntary registration of uh who's
fishing and what they're fishing for
gives you data that allows you to then
balance out where you need to expend
your effort and monitor more closely the
species
um
and so so I would say that without that
kind of data it's very difficult you can
have all of the info on the fish numbers
that you want from surveying them but if
you don't know how many people are
fishing for them uh you're missing a big
key point there I remember that many
years back you did not need a license at
all if you were fishing in New Hampshire
in the ocean
the federal government put down a a
permit requirement and now you need a
license to fish in the ocean as well as
in our Inland Waters that we've always
charged a license fee for and that
license fee
not only protects the habitat and the
fish hatcheries and such but it allows
them to know how many people are fishing
and um
make sure that people are following
guidelines as far as how many fish a day
they can take and such
sorry uh just want to make clear the
explanation from the MR Henke that so in
urban home so for the small scale at
this for the Artisan accessories they
don't need a license but they have still
uh
to report their catch and we also have
the system for that and then for the
small efforts I'm sorry for the
industrial scale and they need a permit
to get the fishing so you are true that
the data is very very important for us
too many TV series and then uh I have a
question for uh for you in here uh I
don't know whether you apply the quarter
system or not and then
uh if you apply the quarter I hear from
uh
fabulous uh day before that they have to
pay for the uh quota before they go
fishing and then what I want to know uh
how do you set a how do you charge the
number of amount that they have to pay
for the quota let's say for headache
let's say is a two dollar per pound or
are you talking about Commerce yeah but
I was a Commerce
you know we don't regulate commerce we
don't so am I am I misinterpreting this
if I interpret it correctly if we put a
quota on on fishermen that they can only
take in a certain amount how do we
charge for that how do we how do we
charge for our licensing that allows
them to take in and where do we cap a
quota uh do we have quotas too was a
question in there yeah
um so so
do we have quotas do we have um limits
that they can hit annually and they
can't do anymore uh they have to switch
to another species if these things uh
how are they charged as well do we
charge people by how many pounds they
bring into the in based on in that is
that how their licensing is done or is
it done as a a flat fee licensing system
those were the questions as far as I
flat fee essentially our licenses are
issued
um based on
what the department needs essentially
and I know we have a commercial level
yeah but then we've also got some
personal ones so that's a breakdown it's
flat for commercial fishermen and then
it's another fee separate different one
if you're just a personal private
fisherman
um
we also have just permits where they
don't have to pay at all it's just you
know like a registration system and such
but it it's
um no it's not based on on what they're
coming in with or what they're Landing
it's just based on
um
actually
what department feels it needs for its
income
so
doesn't each of our licenses
carry with it a limit on take for most
of them
so each if I go fishing I can only take
x amount of trout per day of X size
but it doesn't connect to funding
the department
but there are limits yes there are
limits there are quotas again primarily
based on
what a population can withstand for a
harvest
it it's not um
it's not based on income for the
department or for the state
it's it's based on
the quotas are based on
what the populations can handle for
fishery
um Fisheries that are fishing off of it
and still maintain a sustainable
population and sustained a sustainable
Fishery
and as far as commercially
Cherie do we have a cap on what a
commercial fisherman can land per day or
per month or per season
uh you know it depends on the species
um
again through our collaborative
organizations and such yes there there
can be quotas placed on
commercial some commercial Industries
there could be a limit on how many
licenses are available
to to be able to fish you know that's a
type of quota also again you know when
you're when you're trying to maintain a
sustainable population is the population
and the number of of uh Fisheries that
are going after that population you can
only you can only control the Fisheries
you can't control natural mortality or
that sort of issue so there's several
ways of controlling Fisheries whether
that be quotas whether that be the
number of licenses that are allowed to
fish for for those species and such
so to tie this all up with a nice little
bow
we have a department that is essentially
self-funded through license fees that is
our fishing game Wildlife Management
Department
and they determine licensed pricing for
everything that has to do with needing a
license from hunting to the fishing
aspect based on what the department
needs to balance their budget
also taking into account what is
somebody willing to pay for a license if
the price goes too high you'll have less
of them and now you've got a problem
with managing the species
that's that end then we have the quota
ends which is usually one of those data
points that's a collaborative effort
with the
um associations that we belong with for
the Atlantic Sea Coast and for the North
Atlantic states
and that might mean that we're not
issuing as many licenses for commercial
fishermen because we have a problem we
might put a quota on how many they can
take in in a season
but we don't charge them based on what
they bring in
they pay the flat rate for the license
so in your case is that what Indonesia
does if if I if I bring in a hundred
pounds of fish I have to pay this much
and if I bring in a thousand pounds of
fish I have to pay more is that what you
do
yeah so in Arabic on previously uh if
you want to go fishing you have a need a
license in the permit and then the
permit is depend on the how much or how
bigger the uh vessel do you use in terms
of the Commerce you're facing you know
and it's uh based on the productivity of
the fishing gear and the vessel so the
relation between gear and the vessel and
then we calculate based on the gate the
groston
let's say you have the vessel 100 gross
stones
it costs uh maybe uh expensive for the
vessel with the
uh more larger size
they should pay more expensive for for
the permit and right now we try to tune
a transform from the uh what we saw in
what we call in here is like a lending
fee so right now we uh
apply the program for the lending fee
they the permit is free and then when
they catch the fees they get the fees
okay so it is a bit different
yeah it's essentially like a a tax on
the amount of productivity you have
um
yeah that's why I wonder in here how
much the person uh pay for the permit or
license what does a commercial fishing
um
I'd have to look that up but for
non-residents
um a commercial license uh commercial
salt water license might be I think it's
500 for an for a resident I think it's
um there's there's some graduations of
um of some commercial licenses our
Lobster industry you have your your 1200
trap you have your 600 trap you have
your 100 trap and you have your
recreational so you have these
graduations based on
on that
um you know it it varies based on the
size of the fishing organization so if
I've got a lobster boat and I'm only
going to put out 600 traps I buy the 600
trap license and anything up to 600
traps I can do for that flat fee
okay and if I'm running a bigger
operation with two boats and I need 1200
now I'm buying the 1200 license and I
can go up to 1200 traps it's still a
flat price for the license and we don't
have a tax in New Hampshire for sales or
any of that so
um we don't charge them when they bring
them in
um the fee is strictly for the license
for the ability to go out and then of
course they're subject to enforcement so
if they get fish and game comes up
alongside they're going to make sure
they're not taking short lobsters
they're not taking lobsters with eggs
they're not they're not breaking any
other rules regarding the way that
they're putting their traps out or any
of that stuff
um
we don't
inspect the landings correct
you sometimes Fish and Game enforcement
will go out to make sure they're
following a law but we don't inspect the
landings and count every
amount that is brought in by each
we have
we have a data collection programs that
we will intercept boats on docks and
the individual Harvester
and the dealer to report particular data
but no we don't literally go out there
we don't meet them in and count every
fish it comes off it's the dealer
um that supplies us with the actual
Landings data and it's a harvester that
supplies us with the effort data you
know that they went out for 12 hours
with this particular gear came in with
this estimate number of of harvest so
that we can assess effort involved in
Mr chairman
so so if I'm on the Quan Flats I don't
know what the limit is used to be a five
gallon pail and I take two five gallon
pails I'm not going to meet a game
warden when I'm coming off the game
flats or the coin flaps of course you
will
right do you want me to
so when we have our Landings inspected
by fish and game what they're doing is
they're collecting data and they're
looking for violations of the
regulations okay
they're not charging fees
um the only thing that happens at the
Landing as far as a fee goes is you've
got a dealer who's agreed to buy the
fish and you've got a fisherman who's
supplying the fish and that's a private
deal between them
the state doesn't take any money out of
that deal at all but what we do is we
collect the data
from the fishermen
and the data from the dealers
and that's how we add to our big bucket
of data that allows us to determine how
we have 10 minutes left if anybody wants
I have a question but this is maybe like
out of the Fisheries topic so this
morning my interpreter
I mentioned to ask some interesting fact
that we want just to know uh
is it a good lesson so you can ask us
anything yeah yeah we heard the fact
that you as a representative is the one
who paid very high in the United States
[Laughter]
So based on The Interpreter mentioned to
us
as a as a state representative in New
Hampshire you earn a hundred dollars a
year
that's it and that's before taxes and
before you buy your business cards and
your ties and anything else that's
that's why I don't have a tie I'm broke
um but uh it's yes uh because we have
400 state representatives as I mentioned
with the third largest democratically
elected English-speaking body in the
world
um and if we it's in our Constitution
and it's been there since the 1800s or
so with it they got paid a hundred
dollars a year for their service and
none of us is going to go there and
change the Constitution to get paid more
so we're strictly a volunteer
legislature we all have our day jobs or
we're retired or what have you and uh
and we do not make any money at all we
have no staff as a chairman I have an
office that I share with the vice chair
and another committee chairman so
um most everybody here just has a drawer
in a file cabinet and that's it
um
and that's it's a good question
um but if you go to other states you'll
find that they're some of the highest
paid uh people around but not in New
Hampshire
here because it's different from yeah we
just know maybe if we started charging
them by how many pounds of fish they
brought up we could pay everybody more
but we don't do that
um and how does it work in Indonesia uh
it's quite different yeah they already
have regulation for setting up the uh
representative costs and salary and so
I'd follow up I think this is my first
term here
there's a lot of pride in all the
representatives here that we are a
volunteer group we take that as a very
it's a very personal thing there's a lot
of Pride here that we aren't here for
the money and that we're here for for
our citizens and it's
um in fact we it was brought up to give
us a raise this year and we voted that
down because of the the economic
conditions but uh and we had the
conversation that if we were to get paid
a lot more money it would change the
whole feel of this place and the way
that people respond we think
for example also out there um it's not
just us the Senators there's 24 of them
and they only get paid 100 a year as
well
we don't need term limits
because most people can only handle
being here for free for a certain amount
of time and then they decide I'm done
and someone new runs okay it's not an
elected for Life type of thing because
nobody wants to do this forever for a
hundred dollars a year and
um
every two years our entire government in
New Hampshire is reelected
from the governor straight down to us
the only offices that are different are
the federal Offices because they follow
federal law for their terms their length
of terms but the governor the executive
Council the Senate and the state
representatives here in the in the House
of Representatives are all elected every
two years wow
so if you think you made a mistake in
two years you get to vote them out and
get somebody new
[Laughter]
and I will say I am one of the crazies
here I'm been here 25 years so wow
when you uh I notice you're going to be
doing a tour of the state house this
afternoon you'll get to see the house
Chambers where all 400 of us sit and we
are
put in like sardines into a room with
our chairs side by side
you'll find it interesting
curious that you earn 100 a years but
does the government give you like
incentive for the oppressional cause or
the facilities like car or super special
private jet or whatever
so so I'll start out by saying that um
we get paid 100 a year I'm not sure that
every State Rep earns the hundred
dollars a year
there's a number that they don't even
earn it but
um on top of that I will say that we do
get free tolls
we get to drive through the tolls
without paying
um so that's like saving a dollar when
you go through you know each time
um and we have uh mileage that we get
paid uh so uh it's done at the federal
rate which is 65 cents a mile or
something like that and the State House
knows where we live and where the state
house is so for the round trip to come
from our house to the state house and
back we get paid for the mileage of the
days that we have to come in here
um it's enough for me to essentially buy
me a lunch on a day that that I come in
um or pay for that gas that I had to use
to come in but um there's no other perks
as I mentioned we pay for our own
business cards
um even the special license plates we
put on our car we got to pay extra for
those
so
uh yeah
yeah yes
and mind mine's a special one because
this one was made with this the state
seal and now we have two state seals in
New Hampshire one is the corporate seal
which has the boat and one is the
non-corporate seal the original seal and
that's the one here that's got a bundle
of arrows a pine tree and a fish
and this is the original seal before the
state was incorporated and the person
who used to make these was a
representative who passed away some five
years ago so you can't get one of these
anymore
thanks for sharing any other questions
they don't have to be fish and game
related